Humans are pretty cocky, we like to think
we have the best features, but some animals
have specializations we could only DREAM OF.
Howdy animals, Trace here for DNews.
Animals in the wild are subject to evolution's
guiding hand.
Animals are more like paintings than photographs.
Next time you're at a portrait gallery, don't
just glance at the faces -- look at the items
on the tables, the clothing -- it was all
meticulously picked for specific reasons.
Biology follows a similar process with millennia
of natural selection.
For example, research this week confirmed
part of the reason why zebras got their stripes.
Common wisdom would say it's for camouflage,
or that the crazy stripes cause a dazzle effect
for possible predators, but research published
in Nature Communications is all like, "aww
hellll nah."
It's to fight off little fly bites.
African flies are awful.
Species include tsetse flies which can transmit
fatal diseases even to the zebra.
Flies are attracted to dark colors, and the
short hair found on zebra hyde isn't enough
to keep the fly off their bodies -- but by
studying their visual systems, scientists
conclude the zebra stripes seem to screw up
the fly's vision!
If they can't see to come in for a landing,
then the fly will go bite some OTHER animal.
Nice!
Zebra's aren't the only ones with this less-than-obvious
adaptation.
What do you think the Lion's mane is for?
Making it look big and awesome; or to protect
the lion's neck.
Except, nope.
American Scientist published an article in
2005 detailing 30 years of lion study.
Lions manes aren't for intimidation or protection
-- based on ALL the data, manes are for the
ladies.
Darker, larger manes indicate a well fed lion,
who is obviously good at hunting, and higher
levels of testosterone, which is great for
breeding.
These aren't the only ways animals unexpectedly
adapt to their surroundings.
If you're looking at giraffes you probably
figure, oh... those trees are tall, thus...
long necks?
Right?
BUZZZ, wrong again!
Studying these animals biologists guess the
long neck has nothing to do with the height
of their preferred food source, because it's
extremely dangerous for a giraffe who needs
to drink, bending all the way down like that...
Not to mention, the neck is horrible for the
giraffe's heart -- it has to work REALLY HARD
to pump blood all the way up there!
Giraffe's long necks are to compete for mates,
ever seen a giraffe fighting another giraffe?
They whip their thick-skulled, horned heads
at other males trying to fight for the right
to party!
It's crazy.
Physics tells us this makes their head accelerate
dramatically in comparison to the movement
required at the base of the neck.
Scientists are still studying the giraffe,
but Uppsala University found the necks and
skulls of males to be longer and heavier than
females -- which would support the neck for
sex theory.
I guess we'll have to put our NECK on the
line and really, REACH for more study!
Know of any other unexpected adaptations?
Not like, stripes for camouflage, we're looking
for stuff that's not obvious at all!
Tell us down below or come to GooglePlus,
Twitter or Facebook we're DNews, and we're
easy to find.
Thanks for watching!